is a polish journalist and historian
and one of the last living survivors of
the holocaust
for several years he lived in the ghetto
of lots
from there he was deported to auschwitz
and later to buchenwald after surviving
the gruelling death marches
he was finally liberated at the
regenstad in 1945.
tuskegee decided to stay in post-war
communist poland
as editor and journalist for the weekly
politica
he worked towards reconciliation between
the various communities
last january during the commemoration at
auschwitz
tuskegee gave a powerful speech that
made headlines across the globe
good morning my dutch friends
not only my veterans but mainly my dutch
friends
my name is mariam turski
i live in warsaw poland
and english is not my native
language so do please
forgive me my errors my mistakes
which i will probably have while
lecturing
today
and maybe one explanation
more i'm a survivor for auschwitz
prior to it i was sent to it because of
my
jewish origin prior to it
i spent more than four and a half years
in the gate of which second largest
jewish population
in puerto poland so
in a way i am
a witness of history
by education i'm a story
this is my profession this is my
education
this is my job and i
can understand that rob
riemann the boss of the nexus institute
in amsterdam
invited me to give this lecture
in order not only to present
you i would say an academic
point of view and academic research
but also to combine
academic research
with eye witness
experience thank you bob
riemann and now to the point
the topic is what
did the victims it means the jews
what did the jews know
about their fate
and precisely as well
what did i know
being a boy and then
after several years what did they know
about
my faith
well i can understand
and kai and i can guess
that some of you who are listening
to my lecture would be
maybe even amazed
and they would pose they would say
hey mr trusty what do i do saying
you knew everything you knew everything
[Music]
was hitler was not
hiding his ideas his approach to the
jewels
he lost a full antisemite and not
only he also used
anti-semitism as a tool
in gaining power
in gaining yes
this is true the souls
the hearts the support
of people of the seed
and he announced
his pronunciation were public since the
twenties
everybody knew manny camp
his autobiography publishing millions
made millions of copies was a kind of a
bible
of nazism and in this
bible you can find his approach to
the jews so what are you saying wait
wait you are right
but only to some extent
i will give you in a while some evidence
that
pre in times before the war
even the germans themselves
did not know exactly
[Music]
what would be the fate of the jews in
this meeting
that
they didn't
even guess about a
particular
moment when when
there would come a sudden and violent
way okay of annihilating the jews
and here's my evidence here's my
proofread
probably most of you know
the famous event of
what is known in german as the
kristallnacht
in english it means the night of the
broken glasses
it happened november the 9th
1938 it was in a way
a landmark a milestone
in german and nazi
policy visa visa jews
[Music]
the 9th and the 10th november 1938
there were for the first time
in this scale a program
a total attack
on jewish businesses jewish homes
jewish synagogues
almost all the jewish synagogues were
burned down also of them
the 91 jews were killed at least 91
then the shops were
looted it was absolutely
a knight of broken glasses
one of those who was the
implementer of it and who in the
future would become one of the executors
of so-called final solution of the jews
his name was reinhardt heidrich
who was very close to the narrow circle
of the of those people who decided
upon german police policy
politics hitler and then guering
himmler goebbels berman
maybe some other but those this was the
narrow circle of the deciding people and
heidi was very close to them he was a
favorite
student a favorite supporter a favorite
son i would say
pupil of hitler in a very short time he
would become
probably a member of this narrow circle
who ruled nazi germany
imagine that this hydra
a day or two days after kristallnacht
wrote in a internal memo we have it
in the archives
and i'm quoting it
the process of getting rid of the juice
will take 10 years
under the quotation if that had been the
case it would have
been not before 1948
but it happened something else
well you see he
in his imagination it would
take 10 years to get rid of the juice i
encourage him
to get rid what did they mean
what they had in my heavy mind
while using the word to get
rich the nurses
don't deserve
to be
excused but
as historian i must look into the
source's
objective objectively
and to be very
close to the historical tools in those
days
it meant if
the jews it meant depriving the jews
their citizens right
the the private individuals taking them
away their civil rights taking away
their property
if they only agree to leave
property their businesses
in germany and if they want to immigrate
okay why not we want to have a germany
urden fly this was the idea
of getting rid of the juice in those
days
[Music]
well so
it would something happen
special it would afterwards
what will change their
policy they approach
to jews and not only to jews
and i'm coming to the title so if you
ask me
what the victims didn't know
about their faith first of all
we should fix when it was decided by the
germans
themselves
so we have first of all to determine
when the fate was decided
with and more precisely when the fate
when it was decided to speed up
that weight to accelerate
to sudden violent
excess immediate extermination
you will find in very many
books also in some textbooks still
and such a great
source of information as is the
wikipedia
wikipedia that
this was decided in the valencia
the famous conference in valencia
in 1942 it is
this information is misleading i'll tell
you why
not only because the participants
of this conference which took place
january
the 20th 1942
where not the high the highest
rank dignitaries german
dignitaries only heydrich
who was presiding the conference he was
really one of the
top from the top maybe
closest was the boss of uh gestapo
heinrich mueller and then rather
important details about surgery
the fourth rank vice ministers
deputies of the different ministers
they were not able to make the real
decisions
second point
look the vase conference convened
exactly january the 20th 1942
and since december the 8th
1941 the first
guessing in hong know
in the german commonwealth
was implemented faith
gathering of gypsies and jewels
from so-called vertigo
and we should
have a little bit imagination you cannot
just have an object
ready in one day probably it took them
at least
a month to prepare the place to prepare
the transfer to it and so so so on so
no doubt that the decision
was made at least before
november maybe before
october 42.
yes vanzei was important
very important because it
worked out the logistics
of the so-called final solution of the
extermination of the jews
how many transfers how many cars you
need
what would be the schedule who would be
responsible
for the logistic and so and so on and so
on so
so on but it was only something to work
out a decision which was
debated which was passed at least
several months earlier
prior to it when
there is no doubt that
the so-called barbarossa plan
the offensive hitler's offensive
of russia against russia
and this very cool war
that this was a change
and then combined afterwards
with the pearl harbor
and they were with the uh with the
united states
this was a new milestone this was a real
milestone the landmark
in german policy
let me quote something
very important very interesting
a week before the offensive against
russia
started one of the
most important personalities
of nazi germany joseph gables
was invited by hitler
and this is what he wrote what he put it
down
in his diary
i'm voting
it is the entry from his diary
dates june 15 1941
the most powerful offensive the word has
ever
seen he's predicting what will happen
in one week napoleon's story has no
ground to be repeated
the fuel estimates that the world
campaign
will not last longer than 4 months
i personally estimate that it will take
us
less we are a step away
from a triumph the pact with russia
really was abstained on our honor
the furious says that whether or not the
right
is on our side we must win
there is no other way for us what we
plan
is in every way proper moral
and necessary and when we have
won who is going to ask us
how we did it end of
quotation and now another quotation
i don't want to overload you with
quotation but still
it is part of my job
because those are the sources several
weeks later when
the offensive is
developing more and more and also
they started killing
the communists the jews the aperiticus
and also
by special duties called the einsatz
gopin here you have this
following entry from gabel's
diary i'm voting it is
a life and that's struggle
between the aryan race and the jewish
basilis another government
another ruler would have lacked the
courage to address this question
and solve it once and for all
the fury has shown himself
to be the undaunted pioneer and
spokesman
for a radical solution and that is
precisely
what the present situation demands
praise god there is a war and we can
reach for means that we could not apply
in peace time we must use them
to the full end of the quotation
well i think this is it depicts
the change of their
own attitude of the honor of the nazi's
own attitude
and not by incidents from the same time
i can quote
also something important
the authorization of
second one in germany of hermann gehring
given to hydrash
i directly imposing i direct you to make
all necessary
organizational logistical and material
preparation
for total solution of the jewish
question
in german zone of influence in europe
i direct you to submit to me shortly
an exhaustive plan of organizational
logistical and material preparations
preceding the achievement
of the desired final solution of the
jewish question
and those quotations this was really
a kind he entitled girl entitled
irish to convene the bounty conference
to look for means
for ways how to work out the final
solution
and here the result
of the first year in 1941
after the beginning of the
hitler's offensive which was
during end of june the 41
till the end of 41
600 000 jewels
were murdered in a normal way
by shooting by executions in
the baltic states in the
former eastern territories
of private poland in in the bill
in belarus in the ukraine
and probably you know
special names of executions
it was
venus lithuania fought
nine in covenants lithuania
it was rombola in latvia
it was babinear in ukraine
and here
arises the question what
we didn't know
about the change about this
acceleration to rape it
to immediate immediate
stage phase
of killing of murder
the news about
ponder were the face which reached
polish jews and i will try
to have a glimpse into three
circles three great jewish populations
first around venus
second the largest population of warsaw
and finally i'll come to my town
to watch where i lived and what i
experienced
there were rumors about padilla about
ponari
and thanks to the
corporation even dated
before the war between the
jewish pioneers scouts jewish cows
gathered in the
in the organization
with the scout
organization a clandestine scout
organization
a polish scout organization headed by a
wonderful
gentleman a great hero alexander
kaminsky
they used the nickname
the gray ranks in polish
there was a cooperation and because the
jews were not
permitted to travel
the people the wonderful guys
from the polish scout organization
sent dedicated people
like irena damovic
to those areas
and they brought the report to
deliver them to the jewish leaders
one of the leaders was you probably know
the name because
he was very famous he became very famous
[Music]
and in november 1941
when the scout the pole scout
grabowski reached him and
reported him what happened in his navy
town
venus he was absolutely shocked
he was absolutely shocked and
in his memoirs
he confessed
by the way if you will have a chance to
read them they
were published also in english under the
title
um surplus of memory i'm quoting
it was a great blow that was not
just a pogrom the knowledge
that pornari panerai means death
knocked me off my feet
and this is significant
said this millier the circle
of jewish leaders in the area
of venues of lithuania which was before
the world
polish territory that they
they first realized what happened
their leader a great
personality great absolutely
a poet a fighter may
be some of you know his name abba kovner
he gathered the
main active of the young
jewish fighters in this earlier venues
and the night of
december 31 1941
he declared
publicly to them it was a clan western
meeting
and he declared and this is what he told
them
friends comrades colleagues we are
the witness of a new stage of german
policy
with respect to jews it is the stage
of immediate extermination
and exploitation
at this moment we can say
we can state that the
leaders of vineyard avenues
jews in the end of 1941
[Music]
realized that this is
a new stage in
german policy that it means
immediate annihilation
how was it in warsaw rumors
about cow now about
venus about some other places
reached the warsaw ghetto
in the first months of 42
but my
dear friends you should understand that
maybe i will repeat it
twice or three times
people don't want
to believe that something
that was wrong could happen to them
people still believe
maybe it was only incident
in this place maybe something it was a
revenge
in this place maybe it was a special
couple
nazi commander but they could not
comprehend they could not embrace in
their mind
that a full
nation could be
a goal of examination
my very good friend who also survivor of
auschwitz
maybe you know her name harina birnbaum
a poet she lives in israel
she wrote her autobiography
and she titled it the hope
dies the last this is true
people so long they live
they they have some hope
and therefore it was so it was so
difficult so hard
to understand it to comprehend it
but there were two
facts which
had to disturb this
routine this weight this this way of
thinking
first when zuckerman arrived to the
world of ghetto
with the news and the news were
delivered by the scouts and second
very important as
probably you know the first guessing
started as i mentioned before
in germany which was german
kulmhoff it is a long story
i will tell it in brief
a young jewish boy whom we know
as maybe finding maybe wiener
wiener who afterwards would
obtain a nickname at
groynowski in order to hide himself
while to find the shelter because he was
chased by the germans
was forced to be
one of those who buried the jews
being prayed to it gasped
in kung fu this was the first guessing
the first um
the defense examination camp
which was established
he escaped this alongside how he escaped
the desert filmed disaster movie
that i don't have time now to tell about
it
then he found for
one day a shelter in a nearby 20
kilometers away from the camp
in a little town grab woof
he was looking for the local chief rabbi
rabbi it was a rabbi
jacob schulman he told him
the story and what happened
escaped further on because he was shaped
by the germans
and found a place and a way
to come to the world so ghetto
and after he came towards our ghetto
he was in touch with the
clandestine archive in the warsaw ghetto
maybe you have heard about it there was
a group
headed by dr emmanuel ringelblum
a wonderful historian and they
established
a clandestine archive in the warsaw
ghetto
now because it survived it was preserved
uh not fully more or less 65 percent
now it is on the list of the great
treasures
of mankind of the list of unesco
and people from this clandestine
archive
took an interview with this
islamic wiener
we have it in our archive still it is in
warsaw
when you come you can see it
and he gives the first testimony
how the guessing
in the examination camp
takes place takes place
so what he reported
was afterwards published in the
clandestine
in the underground press in warsaw
so you see two ways
one way the news firm venues
delivered by the polish scouts and
attract to him on the other
way the testimony
of the escapee from the extremist camp
of kumhov
it could change the
idea
of the jews it could
well in a way i would say yes since
this testimony
it was already known in warsaw ghetto
what would what is happening to jews
but am i not exaggerating what does it
mean
it was known who knew it
it knew only the elite
dear friends how can you can you imagine
how many copies anywhere how many copies
of
distribution was distributed a
clandestine
newspaper 200 300
500 maybe even thousand people
people were reading it some were shocked
but in general they did still did not
believe
maybe it happened everywhere but
with a great population of three hundred
fifty fifty thousand or four hundred
thousand jews
would he do the same impossible
impossible
this was the way of thinking in europe
in those days
and therefore i tell you
if somebody knew it it only knew
the elite and
still between even
some people knew about it
it was not before
july 42 when
really the warsaw
ghetto population realized that this is
a new stage in german policy
visa visitors
the 22nd of july 1942
began the so-called
we know it from textbooks the great
deportation
from warsaw in
two months almost three hundred thousand
jews
were deported to the blink to bring
under augustine to blinker
when the leaders of the jewish
organization
understood realize that this is
beginning
of the liquidation of the ghetto and of
the population of the ghetto
you probably have seen the film pianist
of polanski so you can
imagine how it looked in those days in
warsaw
so the next day
all the leaders of the parties convened
gathered together and
were discussing what we have to do
the young leaders among them zukerman
demand it we shall go
out onto the streets we the leaders
we the leaders of the political parties
and tell the jews now
you the with the world
population will be killed
will be murdered we should
start the resistance against the germans
and because our faith
is absolutely i believe the verdict is
past
on of on our fate we should
resist an axe
with a knife what
with every everything possible
i remember that those were the words of
supreme
i want to see the blood on warsaw
streets
before it would be the blood in
treblinka
and it is very important to understand
the most absolutely decent
people disindecent leaders
of the jewish community well-known
leaders
modest with great
merits i will name they by name
it was the leader of the religious party
rabbi zesha friedman he was
one of those who opposed the young
leaders i'm quoting the lord
god will not allow allow the killing of
the world society
if we go onto the streets everyone will
die end of quotation
another great leader zionist leader
professor shipper ishak tripper
said responding
to the appeal of tokyo none of the young
people
importing listen were
required sacrifice maybe
50 000 will die or
even 80 000 but the rest
will be left if we go out onto the
streets
as you want they'll kill everyone
end of the quotation
so
my defense how to
evaluate how to appreciate this kind of
thinking
you cannot abstract
that you have a town with
families jewish families
and those people
those leaders responsible for those
families
they didn't dare to appeal
to start what they were sure would
end with a mass healing
sometimes it's hard to understand
but as a way to understand
the responsibility of those people who
had
the old people and the kids
and their families
to go with no arms
against the germans
does it make sense maybe
and still nobody could imagine
that there could be a plan of a
total annihilation of the jewish nation
but no doubt that this was
the real after the deportations
this was the main stimule
for those who left alive
not very many some between 40
50 55 000 maybe 60 000
who prepared is it
uprising and which and
we know we are proud of it we are really
this is sometimes we call it the second
masada
but no doubt that after the great
deportation
when they realized that there is no
other way
they decided to make their pricing
and also because they were not
not more old people who are murdered
not young kids they're murdered single
young people desperate people
could effort an
uprising so
here we come lastly
to my ghetto to the ghetto forge
the deportations from the woods ghetto
started
in january 1942
and this is significant
till may
they were deported 55 000 out of the 160
000
of the population of the wood ghetto
people of course were shocked
but and he'll also please do
understand our way of thinking at the
time
they were total families deported
first of all those who came forward from
germany from austria from vienna from
prague
from luxembourg and them
and then local people
but in the beginning
because the germans deceit people they
betrayed people
they were telling them
you are you will go to a new
large ghetto where you will get more
food than you get it in the woods
and what was absolutely
absolutely mostly touching the
population which
staggeration hunger
listen i will give you
a quotation from a famous
czech jewish writer who was in the
warsaw in which ghetto oscar singer
he wrote his diary his memoirs
he didn't survive by the way and
he admitted he confessed and i'm
quoting some above all
jewels from the old drive in vienna
except the blow with their own kind of
calm
many say it can't be worse than the
ghetto
hunger outside the ghetto can be greater
and that is imposed important after all
a significant proportion of the jews
sign
up of their own accord they want to take
advantage of the opportunity to leave
the ghetto and
this is a mentality of people who know
that if they will stay alive
they will die due to hunger due to
exhaustion
due to tbc so
if they go maybe it will be better there
was something
in addition in the beginning where there
was a beginning of the ghetto
in 1940 really
the germans recruited some labor people
labor young people to go
to the west the western part of poland
it was the eastern part of the aldrey to
build
auto routes to build highways
and this was a very a very
decimating people job but
they some very many
died but some of them
returned and told yes it was absolutely
unbelievable hard work but we got more
food than he used to
than we were used to it in the woods
ghetto
from this point of view some people
believe maybe this is
also something to new jobs they have new
territories in the east maybe they will
take us
to work there and they will feed us
better because worse that it is here in
the ghetto of which
cannot be
and so
this at first
a first signal
of that it happened something is
utmost wrong
took place in may
why in may 17th
a little community of the little ghetto
not far from which 20 kilometers from
which
babies ghetto was joined was
moved from fabienne to woods
and they told us a story
that in their ghetto was a great a huge
laundry in this laundry
where to this laundry were sent to
closes
to be cleaned and they found
the people in the ghetto and fabianita
they found in their pockets
money from wood ghetto
what does what did it mean what does
that mean
imagine that the woody ghetto
issued its own
currency well versus a fake currency
just to take away there's a good money
from the rules but there's another story
but when they found it they understood
that the clauses
come from people who were sent in
deported to hermano to kunrov
this was the first signal that
we understood where the
the people deported went through
a second or minutes signal
was in july the same year
when the commander the commandant of the
death camp in the homeland in kunvoff
sent a letter to the wouj ghetto
asking whether in this
in my ghetto could be produced
a meal a meal to grain
bowls
this this was something
absolutely horrible but
who knew about it only those who were
close to the letter
those there were some rumors but
people still didn't believe a meal
to gain bones is it
this is so inhuman people can't
couldn't believe in such
inhuman possibilities
and then it was
one month even maybe two months because
the deportation stopped in may
and then june and july
even august were
respectively calm even more
there was even more food in the ghetto
why now we know
because 55 000 people
were kicked out where
went away from the ghetto and there was
some little bit
more food in the ghetto additional food
for those who still were living in the
ghetto
and a new blow and maybe the last one
to understand what is our fate
reached us in the beginning of september
in the beginning of september
september the 1st suddenly
germans
went into all the hospitals in the
ghetto
took all the people put them on tracks
and deported from the ghetto
for this later was announced
in germany it calls uh idege
perez it means a curfew
and they held the elder of the jews is
so-called sometimes he's called the king
of the jews
runkowski had a speech
as he used to doing it at the
square in front of the firemen
quarterbacks
and i'm going now to quote this his
speech
at least part of it because it is really
i'm out of time
the ghetto has been struck a heart blow
they demand what is most dear to it
children and old people
in my old age i am forced to stretch out
my hands and to beg
brothers and sisters give them to me
brothers and mothers give me your
children
yesterday in the course of the day
i was given the order to send away more
than twenty thousand joes from the
ghetto
and if i did not they said
we will do it ourselves
guided not by the thought how many will
be lost
but how many can be saved
i arrived at the conclusion
that however difficult it was going to
be
i must carry out this difficult
and bloody operation i must
cut off limbs in order
to save the body
i have come like a robber
to take from you what is dearest to your
heart
i tried everything i knew to get the
bitter centers cancelled
i succeeded in one thing to save the
children
over 10. let that be our consolation our
great sorrow
there are many people in this ghetto who
suffer from
tuberculosis because they are perhaps a
weak side numbered
i do not know perhaps this is a satanic
plan
but i cannot stop myself from proposing
give me this sick people and perhaps it
will be possible
to save the healthy in their place
i know how precious each one of the sick
is in his home
and and particularly among jews
but at a time of such decrees one must
weigh up
and measure who should be saved who can
be saved
and who may be saved
i don't comment it
this is so moving
so touching so horrible
it is sometimes like
like reading shakespeare yes there's
something of
shakespearean spirit mood
climate and i
i don't doubt that if there would be
a collection of the greatest speeches
in history of mankind this
speech should be enclosed
my defense now
after september 5th
everybody in the ghetto
of which we realized that this was
the new stage it's a new policy
that our fate the
the the verdict was
bust thank you
you